méxico se consolidó como el socio o el
primer socio comercial de eeuu y eso que
estamos en tiempos de pandemia daniela
blandón tiene los detalles muy buenas
noches' daniela bienvenida hola santiago
buenas noches muchas gracias en los
primeros tres meses de año el comercio
binacional sumó más de 150 mil millones
de dólares entre estos dos países pero
las ventas de méxico hacia la comunidad
americana no sólo registraron récord en
marzo santiago este país también se
ubicó por delante de otros como canadá y
china- en términos de intercambio
comercial cada uno representa un poco
más del 14% otro hito que marcó el
tercer mes del año fue que el déficit
comercial de eeuu saltó a un nuevo
récord es decir que es más lo que
importa que lo que exporta y eso se da
por una fuerte demanda interna que está
atrayendo cada vez más importaciones
entre lo que más compró estuvieron ropa
muebles o juguetes y en cambio en las
importaciones de aviones o de teléfonos
móviles cayeron
daniela una latinoamericana llega a la
alta dirección de la organización
mundial del comercio de quién se trata
se trata de la ex ministra costarricense
de comercio anabel gonzález quien fue
designada este martes como subdirectora
general del organismo junto con la
estadounidense estadounidense angela el
art de otro lado del atlántico la
representación en la alta directiva de
la entidad dedicada entre otras cosas a
dirimir conflictos comerciales viene de
francia y de china esta es la primera
vez santiago en casi tres décadas de
historia de la organización que la mitad
de los subdirectores generales son
mujeres y que su propia directora es una
mujer la recién llegada al cargo conoció
con yo igual parece que hay una fórmula
que le funcionó argentina y recaudaron
más de dos mil millones de dólares con
los impuestos a los súper ricos de ese
país así después tan controversial como
aplaudido este gravamen a las grandes
fortunas impulsado por el oficialismo
entró en vigencia en enero después de
pasar la prueba legislativa
la agencia efe reportó datos
preliminares que dicen que hasta el
momento se han recaudado 2 mil 264
millones de dólares unos 10.000
contribuyentes con patrimonios
superiores a los 2 millones de dólares
hicieron su respectivo aporte pero yo
solo representan el 80 por ciento de los
más de 12 mil que estaban obligados
entre los que faltan hay unos 220
millonarios que entablaron acciones
legales para evitar ese pago la ley dice
que estos recursos deben ser usados
entre otros para financiar la política
sanitaria también hablemos ahora de cuba
que está dando una batalla por recuperar
esa histórica industria que tuvo en
algún momento muy lucrativa de azúcar
sin santiago esta isla caribeña llegó a
ser líder mundial de este mercado pero
la que fue su locomotora económica no
logra despegar desde su desplome en la
década de 1990 de las 156 centrales de
producción que había antes de 1959
quedan apenas 56 y sólo 38 están
moliendo en la cosecha de este año
además los 56 millones de toneladas
y recolectados en ese que fue justamente
el año del triunfo de la revolución
cubana se han traducido a poco más de un
millón proyectado para este año esta
emblemática industria se ha visto
afectada por varios motivos santiago sus
equipos obsoletos y los fenómenos
naturales entre otros escuchemos
a partir de 2017 coincidió con la etapa
donde se arreciaron más de 242 medidas
del bloqueo por el gobierno de los eeuu
todos saben a partir de ese año fue que
realmente
antes no se había nos había quitado pero
a partir de ese año empezaron a arreciar
las medidas y cada en cada momento
fueron medidas más intencionadas más
dirigidas a afectar la economía también
de cuáles fueron los resultados de las
bolsas en la jornada oeste del cerro
mixto el mercado alcanzó a ponerse muy
nervioso con las predicciones de janet
yellen según las cuales se veía una
posible subida de tasas pero después las
mattis hoy recalcó que las decisiones de
la reserva federal son independientes
las acciones europeas cerraron a la baja
presionadas por las tecnológicas en wall
street y en américa latina las
principales bolsas cerraron en rojo
santiago cifra del día francia 140
millones de dólares por este valor el
grupo red hot chilli peppers vendió su
catálogo de canciones a una empresa que
se llama hip no sé si somos este incluye
éxitos como antes de bridge y
californication este año particularmente
los artistas están acudiendo a ventas
como ésta
shakira en ajeno sus 145 canciones y bob
dylan 600 canciones las compañías usan
estos catálogos para revender
para su uso en películas o juegos de
vídeo y publicidad comercial gracias
daniel ha estado en la economía buenas
noches
[Música]